[Applause]
this was phil newby before his illness
an active father of two young girls
but aged 43 everything changed you got
diagnosed in may didn't you
behind the smile on this family holiday
he was coming to terms with a diagnosis
of
motor neurone disease
five years on the disease had taken its
toll
and with the support of his family phil
had made a decision to fight in the
courts
for the right to an assisted death he
spoke then of his biggest fear
it's being locked in without any
capacity to
to move only only my eyes and perhaps
eyelids might work
and that i live in fear of that two
years have now passed and phil's lungs
are failing
this is how he spends two hours each day
his legal battle was rejected his only
hope now
a new attempt in parliament to change
the law
this situation is a nightmare and my end
is
most likely to be lingering and
unpleasant
full of anguish and anxiety and physical
suffering
and i don't see why i should have to go
through that in the house of lords
the first step to introduce bill to
enable adults who are terminally ill to
be provided at their request
with specified assistance to end their
own life this should
pave the way for the first debate on
assisted dying in parliament
since 2015. last time it was
overwhelmingly rejected
but campaigners sense a shift more
doctors now support
assisted dying and more countries are
legalizing it
they think this time mps could vote
in favor but there are groups including
many disability rights campaigners
who fear the consequences of a change in
the law
there are concerns about how there may
be pressures towards
going down the route of assisted suicide
instead of
having good support such as palliative
care or good support just to live a life
you want to have
for phil newby time is running out if
law change happens
it may be too late for him becky johnson
sky news